this is a production of Cornell
University all right thanks I look for
that introduction and thank you everyone
for coming around it's been a long road
but at least we're going to I'm
presenting on hydro phenotype in and
then genomics our sister bleeding for
politics ever and maybe for the record
my full name is Abbot we code I saw the
advert it has landed me to trouble it in
China like yeah so I'll be given our
account of my five-year staying on L and
then I will talk about him a little bit
background on Chris ever three studies
that are part of my dissertation and
then some other things I don't look said
we're little be trying to see things
changing cassava so there are a few
other studies I know reported but I'll
just mention them well the first thing
looking forward and then thinking
globally we need to avoid global
undernutrition crisis we should be the
vision of everyone here as a scientist
one thing to note here or see is like
there are millions of people who are in
need of food all around us and another
thing I want to mention is that all this
is from us ate their food assistant
needs pair of 2017 it was unprecedented
so while we have some basic drought
related things we can predict ok whom I
need so so a man of who there are a lot
of natural hazards and all the rest of
them insecurity problems that can lead
to
the security and sudden need for food
around us so I like this picture what we
need to do we need to be proactive so if
we don't prepare we have a little space
and then we have a lot of need people
are hungry and and if we don't have
enough room
um create or produce more food it's ham
week or maybe a lot of people would be
hanging around I'm so a little bit about
cassava when we are talking about global
food crisis cassava is one of those
crops we can depend on to help us manage
food global food crisis I got this quote
from Fe o and he said that cassava was
once regarded as the food of the poor
but he's not becoming one of the crops
that nations depend upon and then a crop
that is affecting the global economy of
a lot of nations and part of the
developing countries sub-saharan Africa
cassava is a key crop that we look up to
you it's so important because cassava
more than 800 million who depend on
cassava daily and globally and is a
unique review he's Hadi and low in feed
crop cassava can travel in a imaginal
areas and one other thing I want to
emphasize upon is that even though
cassava is a food crop is also one of
the crops to depend on upon see
industrialized agriculture in most of
the developing countries
um this is another quote I saw and then
trying to compete with the present
condition where we are say despite it is
potatoes cassava has the lowest research
intensities so it has been like an
abundant crop for a while but I notice
it as some of us are changing we are in
an a period I tagged as a new era in
cassava research and that era I think is
marked with
a lot of increasing funding nest Jane is
one of it and basics and all that
I think Gates Foundation alone I don't
know how much I I don't have the figure
here there are a lot of investment and
interest in cassava research currently
we have abundance of genomic information
improvement in computational and
analytical techniques there is also rich
in human and material capacity and
currently there is a heightened demand
for cassava for food and by offer
especially in Asia and Europe
so the ongoing developments are creating
on the audience need for us to reshape
how we do things and then meet up with
the rising demand for cassava products
but in doing so we need to understand
cassava breeding challenges our ultimate
goal is to increase unity gain over time
and then that we can do when we take
care of so many important factors
increase our solution accuracy selection
intensity and above all if we can reduce
the breeding cycle of cassava which by
the way has a very lengthy a breeding
cycle um it takes up to a decade for you
to release a variety and cassava has a
poor flowering and Sid said we have
limitation plasm and diversity and we
also have the need to get expose or have
access to better tools and that could
range from phenotype in and data
management tools so maybe a little bit
disruption so that leads to some of the
things I'll be discussing one is the
fosston I that is part of my
dissertation is to look at a problem of
phenotyping in cassava so I try to this
the first or the rapid quantification of
quality traits in cassava using potable
near infrared spectrometer well
I need to mention here that most of the
quality traits we we have we want to
improve on cassava we don't have a lot
of high troop and and standardized
method or phenotype in them and I want
to give an example using these two
traits these are carotenoid evaluation
usually it's easy to separate between
yellow and white clones but when you
have a lot of variation in yellowness it
becomes difficult and what we usually do
is a visual assessment we can go for to
go into laboratory instruction or using
high-performance liquid HPLC
chromatography but one thing with all
these method is that one they need
laboratory need standard laboratory
equipment you need skilled technicians
and when we are talking about low
resource breeding institutions some of
these things could be challenging having
constant light and power and all that so
we started thinking about and these are
indirect methods they see visuals Kareem
is an indirect method of quantifying
karate know and instead of just getting
a feel or Battuta carotenoid we are
thinking about carotenoids I have some
other individual components so we are
just at the point of I'm 25 for to
Tecate noise and then going over to dry
matter which cassava on his own is
almost 60 to 70% water and then forever
valuable component our coma from cassava
we need to have a good feel of the drama
that I evaluations so we use the ovum
method and specific gravity method also
like what I emphasize here is the
time-consuming and low precision
specific gravity is just what you are
seen in the diagram here you weight in
air dip it in water try to get it
specific gravity and then from there
derive content and start using it but
currently
there is a development in the use of
Gnaeus technology and I just want to
show like electromagnetic radiation
skill when we talk about years who have
visible lights here covering from 400 to
700 nanometer and me a species between
700 to 1100 nanometer and then you can
have medium Freret a colossal 2500 so a
little bit about knees Nia studies the
interaction between electromagnetic
radiation and their mother so um
earlier studies have proved that once
you are exposed a matter to
electromagnetic energy it could do these
frequencies of vibrational frequencies
that are you can use to quantify the
chemical component of diameter so they
have used it over time to quantify and
then quantify so many modern own
molecular components in many food
samples they are using it in health and
in so many other places what are the
advantages of using is if you know type
in I need to make sure here that you are
it's the newest technology has been
evolving we used to have a tabletop is
still available but the recent
developments we were having handheld and
currently maybe you see some people have
the my ghost lab is working on this
currently you are having near stools in
a very portable format and one may be
good things to think about looking at
the ranges are not aggressive and so
like I explained in the previous slides
looking at what you want to measure with
weather is just nears
need near infrared or covering between
visible and infrared so most of the
things I I I did was with the handheld
which covers both the visible and
meet near infrared region so Nia's is
fast we can scan a example in in a
matter of seconds is non-destructive and
inexpensive is versatile and there one
thing to know is that from the same one
spectrum you can if you have a good
calibration you can derive a lot of
trades at the same time it's here we are
using years we are not talking about
waste and then other has are related
disposal and that are associated we use
of chemical and laboratory method we can
perform anybody can once you train
people this is just like shooting a gun
you just shoot and then it takes the
spectrum so you don't need to be a
scientist a chemist to use Gnaeus to
call a beta so a little bit about
application on years you don't just get
it and then you have to do a little work
about before you start and using means
in your phenotype and so we go through
calibration phase and what it involves
is that first you want to match your
spectral data with a reference meter so
for whatever trait you are interested in
I maybe talk more about carotenoids
before interested in total carotene or
want to much the spiritual value we have
and then you have to go through a lot of
a little bit of spectra pretreatment so
Cora for scattering and their
differences in nature of sample and
order and then match it with a reference
method value you get from the lab or
whatever that looks like a standard form
is your industry then you have to tray
your model develop a calibration model
train and then have your validation
before you can use it to process samples
the house spectral value but don't have
laboratory values so for us in cassava
one of the things we are trying out is
to have a few base because one of the
things we consider before going for
disease we don't just want to get a
desktop that it sits in the lab and also
the one thing I didn't
Shawn is that the desktop is also can be
affected by temperature and all that so
you also need lie sauce and so he's
almost like having a standard laboratory
too so we needed something that is food
based and then that's why we went for
these and we are asking can we just
here we are caught in a cassava root and
then scanning from da region and then
take some scans and then use it in the
LA instead of coming back to the lab or
current things here's a picture of one
of our stations so some of them are
about eight hours drive from the normal
station so you don't want to stay
establish in laboratories and our
stations and all that so one is that we
are trying to develop calibration on
impact cassava root and the next thing
we are doing also trying to just create
a so we went into construction and get
somebody that can help apples with a
grinder that doesn't depend on
electricity so that you can carry these
all around and then even few days to
grind and then homogenized because for
some traits in cassava maybe I show a
picture of if you have seen cassava you
have a variation in thread concentrate
and some trait concentration along the
route so want to homogenize and then see
how that can possibly improve our
calibration accuracy so for objective of
this study is to develop calibration for
major trade carotenoids when we talk
about carotenoids who have been
presenting most times with a carotenoids
but let's just remember that we have a
lot of components of carotenoids that
are also that have health benefits
example is lutein while we talk about
night blindness trying to correct for
karate night routine and other traits
actually active duty are not profit I
mean eight carotenoids but they are
important in taking care of I related
problems because they absorb the
ultraviolent rays that protects your eye
against cataracts and all the rest of
them so let's also not just focus on two
that are ottoman so our aim is to
develop calibration as much as we can
for individual carotenoids dramatic
content and then like I said earlier on
developed and probably compared
calibrations between at a mosh roots and
then we try to see how far we've gone
comparing specific gravity meter and
hoof emitted from using our knees
derived dramatic content to compare with
the existing meter for dry matter so for
reference and calibration development
throughout my walk I had a lot of
collaborations we developed calibration
with people in Ch Colombia somewhere
developed in national lucre researches
to 2 mu DK and for carotenoids we use
HPLC as a reference and lobby's Russian
method in a nursery for dry matter
mostly we use an oven drying and then
specific gravity method for models
I tried compared a lot of pretreatment I
mentioned earlier you don't just your
spectrum has a lot of noise in addition
to the real information you are
interested in so you have to see how
much you can remove the noise so that
you can focus on the view thing we tried
both linear and nonlinear models and
then for validation try cross-validation
between training and validation set
provided the calibration set we had into
two so I am sure you some results to
just emphasize that when we're comparing
calibration between impact and massroots
I'm showing result on to Tecate noise or
transmitted occur at annoyed and then
total karate night at Summa DK just to
prove like from here I mean there are a
lot of things that he sticks to use to
check your calibration model but one of
them is arrow square in cross-validation
and having this high value gives us the
assurance that we are doing something
even from impacts route even though when
you compare in most of these other trees
like dramatic contents we had beta
calibration we mash done the intact but
they are still high enough that we can
use for screening
another thing we try doing is to compare
between the metals were using so here
try developing calibration using
specific gravity as a reference and then
using oven mitt or also as a reference
so that gives us like the real value for
specific gravity and then when you fit a
model with specific gravity you haven't
in years a nice value predicted value
from in tax route using specific gravity
as a reference the same thing for using
the mash cassava root samples they're
using the oven and you have a prediction
from years from the intact and mashed
what we can see here is that were
specific gravity one thing we'll also
did was to try to make sure we remove
outliers I will emphasize that we had a
lot of outliers a specific gravity and
if you just use the raw data the
correlation was really low well we tried
looking at it and then removing things
that we felt like we're really high but
without you we still had like the
relationship between over method and
specific gravity method he's around 0.64
and wanting to report as concern and
consonant use of nears is that if we
develop calibration with Reuven method
and then comparing its knee as predicted
we're having height for relations that
we give so that confidence that whatever
that is predicted from the nearest is
something we can use that it's close to
the values we get if we're trying it in
the oval so I tried looking at some
laboratory values to check was the cost
are we saving anything in deploying
years for phenotype in I looked at lab
you can ask me for the names I removed
them for maybe security so I looked at
two laboratories that are doing years
one so these are different laboratories
so if you want to use the spot enzymatic
or color metric method in on
defying for starch that takes you up to
like 75 dollars P example and I
estimated a for us in a breeding program
like a nursery we have multi locations
on average we are certain to measure up
to have up to four thousand samples in a
year and if you calculate that as giving
you more than three hundred thousand
dollars but if we are using me as these
another laboratory there do specialize
in using years for calibrating for of
phenotype in forced arch our values
drops to 19 and then for us now the good
game going back to maybe a national
breeding program if I I didn't use up to
200 but if I see me that both
calibration and then validating my model
every year I'm spending up to or
investing up to such amount in building
a reference all I will be doing is
having through points spending is about
0.05 from this amount so in other words
if we apply this we are sure that we are
saving a lot for the breeding programs
and this is not just I'm using one trait
we're quantifying for carotenoids these
not to Tecate noise if you go for
selective you have out you select more
than that like what I have seen in HPLC
with individual carotenoids you are
having up to 125 the last example so
with this I think I want to conclude
that m-me has provide a good phenotype
in eternity for the evaluation and prove
Menomonee trees and then this can also
help us discover some novel traits that
we have not been quantifying in cassava
breeding the potable news is highly
adaptable for feud based screening and
then even though we had higher
calibration in mash then on impact roots
what we had and calibration results we
have from the in touch with is good
enough for screening purposes and then
this saves time and then production cost
the nested is to go back have a little
more detailed and study on carotenoids
and since nears opened the door for us
to measure
individual karate noise so want to see
how the individual karate noises
correlates matata carotenoid so it's one
of the ambassadors of cassava is it's
easy here for you to a little background
they say you look as I don't know how
he's looking and these are yellow ones
and if you see far away here the
difference is clear but then in terms of
quantity we don't have so much to say
about it and not just that we want to
check how much we have in their raw
samples it will be interested to also
know the irritation of carotenoids when
we have the products as Gary and again
so one thing to note is that most of the
studies will focus on an avid emphasis
on these on total karate know but it's
big you to Buddha find to the individual
carotenoids so the objectives here would
be to understand if body phenotypic and
genotypic correlation between especially
between TCC and other individual wants
to know why were improving tota karate
now whether we also improving the other
individual carotenoids if we can
understand some of the studies are focus
on TC seed we know the regions are
associated with variation and individual
carotenoids and then check the option of
using gears in improving carotenoids
comparing cassava
so one thing we use here is that we had
about nine hundred and ninety four
cloves and we analyzed these using a
nonlinear resource I should wear mainly
linear model from bascially square
regression we used tried a nonlinear
model because one apart from nonlinear
models capturing non-linear relationship
between your predictive and m dependent
and independent variables no random
helps you to capture the relationships
are no there and then also easily to be
direct and then makes your
resorts interpret evident
linear models that are based on Latins
of principal component
so we tries in nonlinear model to
analyze this and then woody care has
like two trials the training population
is just B's on when they were collected
and then they have been managing to like
replications but we just got them TP 1 +
TP - we had seen replications be a clone
in a trial and then fournier's we had to
the pre and post a plot location we have
data from woody ho to be on con when we
use mod and hundreds and thousands need
Marcus for these and then we focus on
these trades that have automation before
so the result I'll be showing here
muscled EMA closely related to genotypic
and phenotypic correlation so here I'm
showing the narrow-sense heritability
for all the trades and then for the
correlations we saw more importantly one
of the encouraging thing is that is also
shown before that all transmit Authority
which is gives you a value of beta
carotene container he is highly
correlated Matata carotenoid so we are
so sure that why we went proving to
tackle tonight's by having a good field
of all transmit authority in which is
like totally tackle routine there are
other isomers of beta-carotene which are
also they have also high correlation
with GCC but one good thing to repo here
is that for all the traits we studied
they have positive correlation with TCC
which is encouraging
we saw some levels of negative
correlation between the traits but I
think is a good news to know that while
we are striving to improve to Tecate now
we're improving the other individual
keratinized to 4GS model I tried to fit
in some models to check prediction for
carotenoids so our sure these I hope you
remember but maybe I went for size on it
in a slide so that you don't forget so
one thing is that usually when you have
your raw data is like a usual practice
we do it
to stage approach force feet in your
model and then take care of different
factors and get your blog Museo
blob-like estimated value to fit in the
genomic blob so that you can get your
estimate a breeding values but the one
staged is like a project to the one
stage means fitting in everything from
different locations at the same time so
and then we report calibration using
single trait and mati trait who have
seen that most times you can improve the
prediction of low heritable trait using
either a highly correlated with other
traits and we tried using multi trait
method also and then we compare that
with nonlinear methods using random
forests - don't worry I think I will I
try to cover it so that you can remember
so you have trouble try to remember was
the prediction accuracy for this so once
more don't forget that is a single trait
two-stage prediction accuracy this is a
multi trait linear d-block linear model
using a single Motty trait and here you
have the random forest in two stage here
you have single trait using one stage
and Motty trait one stage and then
nonlinear random forest one stage so we
have values for that trait but I'm
trying to use these streets we
illustrate that most times what we saw
is that multitrader semester was we're
doing a little bit better on average
compared to the single trait model but
that reversed when we use the single
stage model so overall using nonlinear
model was doing a little bit better than
in your mother so the result is about
the same for that trait
the next thing we did was to fit a gos
model for other traits
I hope my stars are really showing very
well I tried expanding and realized this
cottage move so one thing we found out
is that even though we didn't have any
significant afar carotenoids and 14
further traits we're able to discover
some regions that were significant for
most of the traits we studied especially
in chromosome 1 for lutein we have up to
about 5 regions and then 4 to Tecate
know as a mu so the beta carotene
components chromosome 18 so overall we
were able to track look at the genes
that are related to carotenoid in in
cassava and we saw like two basic genes
have been reported one this has been
reported with 40 CC and now we are
reporting if not just for TCC before the
individual traits and then this also
also another gene we we found out within
those regions but then for the other
significant regions we didn't see a lot
this has been reported many studies we
didn't see but we found a lot of stud
genes that are have biological functions
that we believe there may be further
studies can help us understand the
relationship with carotenoids another so
in conclusion we have seen that if we
are utilizing nears its roof a sleep aid
not just understanding carotene oil will
change the way we are doing things if
you know type in and then that gives us
hope in further study in the
relationship between TCC and other
component Ares that we have not been
looking at and back help us redefine our
selection index and all that one good
news is that we got a positive
correlation between thesis and
individual traits and we verified a
major trade agenda was been reported for
variation in TCC alongside other regions
previously reported and we're shown with
the level of accuracies we got that you
can use GS to improve carotenoids in
cassava so quickly trying to make sure
every time the last study that is part
of my dissertation is part of the things
I said we have assays to snip marker
information and we're asking how can we
use it to redefine Nasri system in
cassava so a little bit background I'm
showing a poly cross we have a 2d idea
and one thing we need to do is that and
making control process in cassava is
very difficult one is a little bit of
yours we have closed that flower early
two moons from two months three months
after planting and other ones that delay
but within the same clothes our flower
within the same flower in them but I
have the same flowering happy we see a
lot of variable flowering habit some
close the open up early in the day so if
you are used to crosses maybe it's very
difficult but is something I did like
every day so some clones we opened
between L in the hours of the morning
why some clones you have a bridge
crossing scheme and you're waiting for
the female maybe the man has open and
then where you need to call a flower the
other one has not opened after wait some
time before you go to the next board and
come back you realize that it has opened
behind you so a lot of variation and
then a lot of magic in cassava that you
need to love before you can India and
working cassava because also so one of
the things I did by John you said is a
managing casual workers we hire
sometimes you have to hire up to 20
people for crosses and all the rest of
them is not cheap at all and producing
boo
Danika seed when you are doing had
others kind of variation and then to get
seeds that you can completely say that
these are true crosses most times easy
enough to design in a scheme of up to 20
clones are not a resume in those risky
you might end up getting five thousand
in a year and that is not good enough
for any valuable breeding program so
that is one of the things we are looking
at and what had previously breeders have
tried relying on form of open
pollination to improve creased increase
the production of botanical seen or one
problem and one of them is fully cross
which is more like isolation and then
you pick your clothes that you're
interested in and then plot them in
isolation and allow them to miss
naturally so you don't have a problem of
trying to control it but the problem
here is that you laughs food parental
information so you don't know the
pudding do not know that right so they
have used it and then we are asking the
equation can we use the available marker
we have to see who can resolve and
modify these kind of schema cassava so
you can get a lot of seeds from open
pollination but then you need the
progeny yeah true parents so what we did
was to design a poly cross using the
same method I'm just showing a kind of
design on what you have to do you need a
good design so that you can implement
this is not like well cassava is
naturally and are crossing crop but you
still need to introduce a lot of design
so let's see this is one clone so you
want to make sure you randomize it such
that you have to possibly increase the
probability of each cross and
intermitting with a neighboring clone
that is not itself so for this we
selected 29 clones from our genomic
selection pipeline girls I have high
gbbs and one thing also we consider was
trying to be sure that those clothes
have a
by the same flowering habit so that we
don't introduce well cassava is an issue
but then you still need to use tea see
that between sunflowers do they flower
early but they still have an overlap
between the long ones so but we try to
choose the ones that have an average the
similar flower in habit we try bringing
them randomisation using modified this
quasi Latin square design and then for
isolation
we tried observing 50 meters looking for
a few that has a kind of 50 meters
distance from any neighboring cassava
phobia we succeeded we're lucky we spoke
with the young breeding program so they
gave us a site with India am reading
program and yam yam experiment so we had
a lot of em around this side and then we
were sure that we don't have any
neighboring cassava clone around but for
this study well the effect of the seed
production we succeeded in getting up to
17,000 seats that we processed and
fallujah they were modern since 5000
people just harvested and I know that
would be a gia produces more supports
more flowering and that shows us that
with these in terms of seed production
at least we are covered and then we are
faced with the issue of how do we is it
possible we can at least derive or have
a hood on the parantha or clothes that
contributed to those progenies so we use
about three to eight seeds they clone
out of the 29 replications we had in the
field and one approach of the parentage
is using a relationship matrix
idea is that if genomic markers across
the genome can be used to measure
genetic similarities can we look at the
genomic matrix and then use the
coefficients of relationship matrix to
say something about parentage
a relationship of clones progenies with
parents so
that also we tried another approach
using an analyze regression so we looked
at this as a regression problem and
trying to fit the genotype of each
progeny a tip at a time against that of
all the putative parents that are
involved in this scheme and then get the
confident coefficients and then using
lasso as if as a restriction to put down
some coefficients that are around 0 to 0
so the data set we use for this we try
simulating data set to represent
typically what we can have in a breeding
program we'll have a simple model where
we have like from each by parent across
who have one seed and then we for here
we assume like we have like a uniform
and random distribution going from
parents to progenies and another case we
tried is simulating the second one but
here we use rahem allele frequencies
using one of the data from him across in
mastery of our programs iit a just
getting the whole thing and then using
even the number of snips and the nesting
and also we tried to increase the number
of progenies so we have progenies are
related in the scheme and also the last
thing we did was sorry I should have
reference you use the written language
scheme to bring in a level of since we
assuming that we have a random
distribution and any heritance here can
we account for the engage and then in
case in a pool where we had before do it
as always a crossing who have a mixture
of true crosses and surfing is there
where we can separate the two so we try
see a simulated data set has both true
self and then true and process we also
got data from our breeding programs
knackery and ITA
Beatrice in Missouri we had about 379
crosses from Mochrie and then 764
progenies coming from a mixture of 80
progeny 80 parents and their lastly we
use those methods to check
the poly cross experiment we had in Puma
DK 2015 so the traditional assignment we
got one here reporting the three methods
are the two methods and then for the
simulated data set we were able to
account to say okay e to parents there
are two recorded parents how accurate
are we in getting two of them so what we
did is to rank the coefficients we go
from the two methods and then the
topmost two we want to like give them
the chance that our assumed that they
should be different of the progeny
involved so for those top two parents
how sure how do they relate with the
written record so for the simulator
results we add hundred percent accuracy
using the two methods
but when we go to the data from the
breeding programs we had a level of
shift in accuracy is not 100 percent but
then some of them were a bit low and
then for predicting male so it showing
like okay if they wrote male how
accurate are we in predicting the male
that is recorded against predicting the
male that is recorded for our progeny in
all we realize the accuracies we're
slightly I am analyze regression and
using regression will realize
relationship method even though most of
them we're still like about the same
range but accuracies in female we're
mostly better than in email which
ordinary should be the case because
you're harvesting seeds from the plants
so well while we are still asking a lot
of questions this is one of the initial
studies still room for development and
improve on some other things but we are
looking back on some of the things that
can affect or Ohio expected outcome some
of them range range from long
receptivity of the stigma cassava stigma
the normal process usually you make a
cross you cover for about 48 days but 48
hours but now we have seen that
from some experiments that are coming up
specially from seeit the actually knows
that some autism plume still stay viable
or receptive up to five days so we might
have to change it could be possible that
why you cross was not the one that was
taken and clone mislabeling that was
also affected the experiment we had at
Moody K we gave people a design like row
column and then somebody's reading plot
number in a zigzag method where we give
you from one direction one to twenty
nine and you should come back to stop
I'd see from here but somebody starts
from this side so those things also it
can also happen when we are cutting
cassava use for teas and other cool
introduce miss labeling in the few that
were you Apple in igloo might actually
be something else bugging conditions
with experience I realized that is not
like maze where you bag and then three
we really use backs when sometimes over
years and that is giving us an idea
maybe we should start asking questions
looking at what is the effect of those
battery usage whether they're open hosts
that these also eventually used cross
and we clone that while we cover and
think we have covered they were not
really covered so those are some issues
do not have in error so we are still
trying to understand more about a study
and like I said is the initial one
another thing we ask is okay if you want
to separate between through process and
where you have probably soften events so
we tried to look at the coefficients so
here I'm showing a plot of the top most
number one predicted per and the
coefficient of the where top most parent
and then the second one so when you plot
it we have seen a kind of pattern that
most of them are within the true cross
sees within contribution of fifty
percent from both parents they're about
four therefore safe materials we are
having something hired and that he's
hired a hundred here because we use a
percentage of all the coefficients we
have so
you might ask why is it above 100 so so
with that also we try to get the ratio
between these the coefficient of the
first one and the second one and we
realize that if is about 50/50 percent
contribution it should be about one
order above what values that are both
free or that we give them a red sign
both of them should be self material so
the same thing goes with the diameter
I'm just writing for the last method so
in conclusion we
easily use the abundant market
information to redesign one the
advantage we have here is that we have
access to abundant seeds that we can use
to increase diversity improve accuracy
and then if we have a good recombination
between those traders also given a good
news that we can use the method and
current genomic selection scheme and one
other thing is that we can with this
method be able to have a hold on the
true parents of those progenies and that
would give us also if we are talking
about combination in all from our
results we used 29 parents and in most
of the methods up to 28 parents even
though we use about 6% of the season we
generated showed up as one of the top
two parents so what is sharina's I will
have a good hood of random combination
of all the parents you have in a
population so that's good and there we
can be thinking about trying to compare
and get combining abilities between
those parents and back and also redefine
what we're doing cassava so in all I
think try to be time nears come from
more phenotyping of known and emerging
quality traits we can use improve
phenotyping computed abundance genomic
information a good hood is that is good
tools to do more in added five regions
around there are significant for
variation in most of the non traits and
currently we are doing some work to
identify some and user preference traits
so we still need to have a good hood of
good infinite typing for all those
traits and then we can use you know why
traditions to fast-track genetic in a
chaton cassabi didn't cycle and the last
thing i showed is that if we use the
abundant markers we can to stop at a
good we have a good results you are
still going to study more and and
develop on it but if we can do that
that gives us a good hold on changing
the pattern and breeding method
reshaping and redesigning breeding
method in cassava
so I want to just mention because over
time some other studies I was fully
involved implementing years in NRI I
have data for calibration for starch and
pasting protein cassava I'll be working
on that after now I this part of the
kind of mentoring program one of the MSC
students that in energy is trying to
compare the audiometers that people have
developed for TCC IJ from a mamita and
using comparative color chart so over so
trying to also helping me as graduated
and then we have saluted our people now
and other things we tried doing we have
bit effort to be working at the end of
the program trying to stand as I that
dies between the dextrose och has it a
desktop nears and we have the pata
bunions and they have developed cassava
calibration based over three years of
for model so we are trying to see how we
can standardize between the two devices
and possibly hear it yeah database in
happiness improve on calibration model
in Africa and then I was involved in few
studies trying to understand energies
are preferences and all so publication
we have some of these already written
and they're ready to go this one was
like collaboration and then trying to
put somebody up in yes technology too so
we saw meet early just like two weeks or
three weeks ago and the first study
published in PLoS ONE and then involved
in general GS and energy and project so
with this a whole lot of people I have
the best committee members and then
thanks to Allah members both Sora's lab
and John Luke's lab want to thank people
like Denise and all the rest of the
amazing force in Anna's here everyone
and most importantly I want to thank the
Gates Foundation and Reba Gates himself
I wish sometimes I think he has the
option of using his money for something
else but that's good we Lin trying to
invest it in Kesava research has seen
some of us doing some of what we're
talking about so I want to appreciate in
we have collaborations with a lot of
brightest yet and a saranac me another
race and Oh somebody I want to mention
she was one of the people that
encouraged me to apply for the first
time I met her I was like well I think I
don't think I know much about yes she
was like no go for it go for it apply
let's see so I wish she's around so they
had a I went for it and then I'm
presenting today well those are some of
the Oh stories I know the rest I want to
thank my family it was rough my wife and
I have a little boy that he's trying to
reshape my life it was difficult or the
way especially in 2018 I almost gave up
like one of the shocking moments lost
one of the people that were so close to
me a biological mom she told me go I
will be dealt with receive me when you
finish
so those are emotional moments I just
taught myself to do try and behave
myself so thanks for listening and then
I'll be happy to take some questions
[Applause]
for me germinating I think it was your
second second chapter a single step
model and 2 step model and for some
reason we're two step was doing better
than the one step no there's no reason
why I mean it's the reason why did you
should be different right unless you
give the true values that you're using
are different or explanations yeah I
guess I'm really issues this photo ID
when you get it so for here when you're
usually there single state motto for
single trait I just write what I mean
using the single stage are not into
athlete we had reps on all the rest of
them because we don't have balance and
beta only used location and set and we
still had like something higher than the
two stage I mean for once they should be
the ideal thing but no I I don't live
there people from genever
any other questions we go hey um do you
think of cosmos like taro turaga sets of
Hawaiian room those are similar sorry
and that's your said central question
it's a lion okay also yeah um we call it
in Nigeria similar yeah the they don't
do root crops I thought I have a lot of
each other woods
[Laughter]
this arrow is always like little small
and then different and cassava is almost
like a shrub and that kind of so they
are different
yeah but they are all
in the in the last chapter there was a
thing where you dictate which one's the
damage the data the females not 100% if
somebody recorded which plan things get
off up and that plan is the correct plan
then you should that should be a hundred
percent right so then is is that can you
go to that's life
is that female value essentially the
maximum possible without Yugi
you know without quality no human
qualities goal and then and then if
that's true yeah like so for example in
here a beautiful one they're like let's
save the penalized aggression and the
females in eighty percent of males 76 so
so if you think about your ability to
actually predict that it it's really a
lot better than yeah this event that
neater than you're saying right so so I
guess these another way that you can ask
the question of how how you should think
of the name so how you can get those
female prediction actors things to be
better yeah I mean this is the initial
thing and then when we saw their desire
but it was like okay we need to check
back and ask a lot of questions we had
discussion with some of the breeding
programs and people and even we see it
that was when she borrows so does that
covering and removing the bag within two
days doesn't solve the problem some
things could also happen but then for
female we actually expected to have like
hundred percent accuracy if everything
is alright so like I said there are
other factors we are not sure of we're
looking up to see how much we can do and
if possible going forward set up more
like ether experiments to see if we can
right so you know we're gonna let a
system where when you make across a lot
of things coming to the ISD stem
Cotton's most times these are done by
casual workers and you are having 50
they are caught in every day one is
flying from here to the other point you
can also mix up clones I know that so a
lot of things that we have - we are
improving trying to improve quality
control in Casa so we use these markers
were using for GS I know something yeah
I know some people have done some
studies looking at that you can use opt
I was talking with someone that
development package he said that from
his own experience he can use up to like
he was as low as 200 if you are sure
there is a lot of polymorphism between
those traits that you can capture use as
low as 200 or thereabout so bow for us
we didn't go into that some who have
done some studies on that but just for
like a simple thing we are using I still
want to Ronnie may be within my GS
pipeline now going into extra walk to
genotype or Lou for specific markers to
do that if I just uses a random and then
simple straightforward approach so
my name is here he's the quality champ
quality control champion is the new
initiative we are asking a lot of
questions we have seen a lot of things
and we are getting to ask deeper
questions can we change in region we
have a so this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu